Okay, let's get started!
All of us Japanese here
We're all on the same ship
We're all survivors
Don't you keep it inside
Let it all out
What's inside your heart?
I can't rap.
Hey, man! "Can't" isn't allowed here!
We don't have a road
Or firm ground or time
Let out your frustrations, man!
People in this country are so subdued
They're all good-natured and timid
They're worried about appearances
They're introverted, insular
And do things in groups
They treat you like a freak
If you're different
So damn picky and hammering down
The nail that sticks out
It's totally different
Than foreign countries
I'm glad this country is sinking!
But I won't be taken with it!
Hey there, Japanese dude.
He's dissing Japan, man!
Come on, give him what for!
Let's hear your answer!
What? Well...
Hey, you there, smart-aleck
Quit talking big
You go complaining that you hate Japan
That negativity is so totally Japanese
There's little difference
Between individuality and selfishness
If you assert yourself too much
Life just becomes painful
And what's wrong with being good-natured?
Getting your wallet back
When you lose it is awesome!
We don't hurt others
When we worry about appearances
That consideration shows our kindness
That's what I like
I admit we can be picky about details
That's why we've got such good service
Thoughtfulness and accuracy
You complain we're too serious?
That's our special talent!
Everyone in the world trusts
Made in Japan!
You can connect to the world
Just through the Internet
Quit talking big just because
You think you know it all now!
If you hate it that much
Then get the hell out!
If you regret it someday, what do I care?
Yes! You can do it! I knew you could!
Okay, lady. Now it's your turn.
Don't sit silent, now's the time to talk
I'm sick of your whining
Foreign countries and Japan
What the heck is the point
In comparing countries?
Every place has its good points
And its bad points too
There are good people and bad people
And people that are neither
There is crime everywhere
Miracles can happen anywhere
I'm sick of everyone's opinion!
I'll decide for myself!
There were never any lines
On the globe before, so why now?
It's nonsense to judge
What people from a country are like
I've finally realized this
And at a time like this
It's way more important who we're with
Than where we are
If I can be with the people with me now
I can survive
This is my land, this is Earth!
Do you want to try, old man?
I'LL PUNCH THE PEOPLE WHO MOCKED ME
You're really going to do it?
It feels better, right?
You do it too, KITE.
I never keep anything inside.
You sure don't.
Hey, guys.
Let's take a photo.